ll politique josée legault jonathan
trudeau michel ces objets bonsoir
bonsoir la ministre on négociera pas en
public mais est-ce qu'on compte qu'on
semble comprendre c'est qu'elle vient
d'avoir une épiphanie un peu partout et
que ça prend rapidement
plus de policiers à montréal avec vous
mais celle ci roger vous suivez ça vous
êtes ici beaucoup qu'est-ce que vous
décoder dans est ce que la mairesse a
dit tout à l'heure en disant j'ai
confiance en mes policiers j'ai mes
policiers c'est un peu un plaidoyer pour
les policiers est ce que la mine et ce
dit
je pense que d'abord il faut régler le
problème mais ce qui intrigue policière
toute la chicane entre la fraternité et
la ville c'est pas nouveau un moment
donné dans une crise comme c'est pas
utile de faire cette ce genre de de xian
nord justement il faut savoir qu'au de
combien de position des besoins de plus
de combiers position de besoin sur le
terreau et à s'occuper de ça et la
mairesse aussi a fait en fin d'article
il faut travailler aussi le plan
politique c'est à dire elle demande
l'obligation de ne plus avoir d'avenir
de points qu'on interdise les armes de
poing il va falloir qui est celui qui
était appelé là dessus donne une vraie
réponse parce qu'on n'a jamais la
réponse est non à la fin on est je me
dis pourquoi pour ne jamais dit si on
n'était pas prêts à le considérer ce que
ça change de la donne il faudra le
savoir où l état demande madame plantes
que l'on voit l'était je le rappelle aux
gens en conférence de presse il ya à peu
près une demi heure elle a des demandes
auprès d'ottawa dont bannissement total
et nos projets les deux nouvelles armes
de poing et à québec encore une fois et
josée legault et elle demande quand même
plus d'argent pour que le spvm plus
faire face aux défis quoi
oui mais on ne sent pas de plan
d'ensemble est ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui
c'est sa selman conférence de presse
convoquée en catastrophe avec 40 minutes
de retard j'insiste là dessus quand même
donc ça veut dire que tu as à bras c'est
un petit peu dans les coulisses et
pourquoi parce qu'il ya eu deux meurtres
peut-être plus spectaculaires que ceux
qu'on a vus avant mais il y en a depuis
plusieurs mois ce qu'on a besoin de
rappeler ici c'est tous ces jeunes qui
ont été tués dans plusieurs quartiers de
montréal
donc il ya une escalade mais elle dure
depuis bien avant hier et moi j'ai vu
une mairesse qui n'avait pas grand chose
à dire dans les faits à part que oui
elle a discuté avec deux premiers
ministres aujourd'hui oui avec la
ministre la sécurité publique mais j'ai
rien entendu de concret et là je ne
parle pas de stratégie policière là mais
vraiment comme chef d'orchestre la de ce
qui se passe à montréal en ce moment qui
est extrêmement inquiétant et j'ai
entendu aussi la chef intérimaire du
spvm sophie roy dire qu'ils vont
concocter de nouvelles stratégies
policière justement mais de toute
évidence ne les ont pas encore donc il
ya quelque chose qui m'a un conte cycle
de la méfiance en qu'administration
plantes le spvm la fraternité des
policiers pour toutes sortes de raisons
mais là je pense que la mairesse le faut
qu'elle re construisent des ponts aussi
avec ses policiers parce que là la
prévention c'est important mais là on
est dans une situation où ça prend des
enquêtes où ça prend du renseignement de
l'intelligence et répression beaucoup de
ces pas de cinq ans et aussi parce qu'on
a way beaucoup de policiers se
souviennent josé jonathan michel que la
mairesse plein dans un congrès de son
parti voulait faire une proposition pour
réduire le budget de la police elle a
dit non finalement bon bref disons que
chez le policier moyens même jeu les
gestionnaires à montréal on se dit pas
que madame plantes c'est la meilleure
amie de la police l'attend ou à raison
jonathan est là c'était disque est là et
quand madame guilbaud dit on atteint
comme des chiffres des demandes d'amm
montréal à le sous texte qu'ils fassent
leur devoir qui nous disent qu'ils
veulent
moi ce qui me frappe là dedans c'est
l'absence de leadership clair
d'un intervenant ou d'un autre j'aurais
tendance à penser que la ville de
montréal doit voir un leader seclin fort
mais personne ne l'a ce convoi de
présence en présence de tweets en
twittant parce qu'on a beaucoup une
gouvernance par par tweet on veut bien
paraître mais c'est que le gouvernement
fédéral va dire bellion va de nos moyens
aux villes mais se trouve elle d'agir la
ville va dire moi j'ai besoin des moyens
du gouverneur provincial je vois fédéral
la ministre il faut nous dit c'est pas
nous qui allons faire les plans
d'intervention bref on voit tout le
monde se relancer la balle un peu et
aucun de tous ce biais les policiers que
qui veut se demande mais qui va nous
aider qui vaut réellement nous appuyer
nous donner les moyens madame planté le
beau dire qu'elle aime ces policiers il
reste que vous l'avez bien mentionné
patrice il n'y a pas si longtemps que
son parler encore de la possibilité d'un
espèce de concepts ou de contexte qui se
prêterait à des finances et à posséder
une espèce de des financements la police
or on peut parler de préparation je
pense que c'est important de le faire
c'est essentiel mais on le voit dans le
discours du premier ministre oncle aussi
la répression mieux outiller les
policiers je pense que ça va être au
coeur des des propos des propositions
mais il faudra vraiment qu'il ya des
gestes concrets qui vont venir appuyer
les policiers sur le terrain oui comme
dit josé la conférence de presse
il n'y avait pas d'annoncé très précises
on va dire ça comme ça c'était un
plaidoyer senti on sentait qu'elle est
ébranlée mais
ya pas de plan de prêts en tout cas
c'est ce concombre il y avait beaucoup d
y avait beaucoup de bosses intimae de
voeux pieux mais
font drion une je vous ramène à roanne
je vous faire entendre monsieur boileau
et ce matin entre thomas gerber with sur
notre site a fait tester dans un
laboratoire des poussières dans des
maisons de ce fameux quartier notre dame
à rouyn qui jouxte cette fonderie horne
et les taux d'arsenic à l'intérieur des
maisons dépasse les taux permis même sur
les terrains à l'extérieur je vous fais
entendre monsieur boileau qui dit oui on
le savait en passant et il faut que ça
change vite on écoute
le sucre à pau nous le savions nous
avons fait le point là-dessus
régulièrement dans les dernières
semaines la direction régionale de santé
publique s'était déjà préoccupés de
soyez avait demandé qui ait des actions
qui soient prises plusieurs ont été
prises mais on devrait faire le point
très bientôt sur cela ce sont des
informations comme je vous dis qu'il ne
nous surprennent pas en eux des données
qui sont en parallèle deux sauts et je
pense que ça nous invite à agir d'une
façon solide pour encourager la
décontamination des sols du côté de
rouyn noranda
c'est comme si dans ce dossier la pitié
pas de nouveau en passant on en parle
depuis des années la boxe en parle
depuis trente ans on en parle dans
certains médias depuis plusieurs années
et c'est comme si les gens marchaient où
étaient immobiles et veulent tout le
monde se met on a l'impression à courir
après le temps perdu jonathan
shaw ce terrible je trouve ça terrible
et et d'entendre le directeur de santé
publique dit oui oui nous nous le
savions vous savez qu'il ya une
situation qui est inacceptable et qui
perdure non pas depuis des années mais
depuis des décennies imaginez-vous donc
notre notre collègue des médias alain
laforest à l'époque où il travaille pour
être jaune or en 1988 avait réalisé des
reportages sur des concentrations sur
des terrains de citoyens qui dépassaient
les normes en 1988 ça fait plus d'une
trentaine d'années on en arrive avec les
mêmes constats cercle énorme avaient été
revus mais il reste qu'il ya des
résultats qui sont tout aussi alarmant
moi je trouve sa tragique pour la
population de rouyn noranda imaginé il
ya une semaine à peine on avait mis 10
qui nous dit ouah mais pas personnes qui
vont mourir de sa garde et dans le cas
de rouyn noranda il ya des preuves qu'il
ya des statistiques qui démontrent
notamment que vous de l'espérance de vie
les chances 2-2 d'abord le camp semant
la terreur des statistiques sont le fait
des années qu'on le sait et le
soudainement on est toujours à la
remorque on est en réaction au travail
des journalistes au travail de député je
pensais roux travail la députée me
lisent les sentais rien je trouve ça
franchement franchement 1 avr j'y vois
le temps devance jose
ben je partage tout à fait de cette
opinion la et
lorsqu'on écoute le docteur bois luz
juste l'extrait que vous avez pas assez
écouté le flou il ne dit rien non plus
il ne dit absolument marier sauf que
nous avions des actions prises pour
lesquels il n'y a jamais de détails on
ne sait jamais vraiment ce qui se passe
et ce qui se passe c'est très clair
c'est que et c'est un ont pensé que
c'était une situation révolue que
c'était une situation d'une autre époque
mais ou une multinationale fait la loi
et l'ordre finalement dans une petite
ville parce que l'emploi les gens parce
qu'elle leur donne des salaires mais
employer des gens ça ne donne pas le
droit de les rendre malades et
potentiellement de les tuer donc il ya
quelque chose là de
pourri dans cette situation là on
pourrait comprendre dans les années 40
dans les années 50 c'était un le
capitalisme à tous crins tout seul mais
aujourd'hui et d'entendre encore
toujours des déclarations floues
lorsque cette compagnie là il faut tout
simplement et lé milliardaire cette
compagnie là il faut la mettre face à
ses obligations
lui donner des critères d'application
beaucoup plus sévère et c'est tout sinon
ben excuses et on trouvera une autre
solution mais là c'est c'est tout et
toujours c'est toujours du pelletage par
en avant et pendant ce temps là les gens
qui résident dans ces quartiers là sont
prises en otage machine à vendre il à
michel
laville réponse que monsieur boyoud pour
elle aujourd'hui si on le savait c'est
ce qui est donné comme réponse on est si
vous le saviez pourquoi il s'est passé
quelque chose et ici on dit c'est comme
ça dans tous les recoins de ce dossier
là chaque faute d'autres collègues
gerber ou quelqu'un dont tamim avec eux
on s'aimait mais on n'a rien fait à un
moment donné il va y avoir un effet
d'accumulation pleine campagne
électorale qui sert de loupe pour qu'on
regarde ses deux plus proches qui s'en
vient ça pourrait devenir très explosif
cette situation là en campagne
électorale parce que encore une fois la
pire réponse est on le savait si vous
saviez pourquoi n'avez vous rien fait et
là ça implique pas seulement le
directeur national de la santé publique
ça avec quelques gouvernements du québec
et fiable par la campagne électorale
j'ai un petit tableau
qui a été préparé ce matin par véronique
prince de notre bureau de québec un
texte sur notre site le journal de
montréal aussi avait un article
pour les libéraux je vous expliquais
dans la bonne séquence donc c'est la
cagnotte de l'argent ça reste importante
campagne électorale la cagnotte des
partis c'est leur trésor n'ont pas juste
de guerre mais les leurs la valeur
qu'ils ont le politique vont tout dépend
c'est ça la caq 6,8 millions en rose
parti libéral en baisse une partie
libéral pour avoir une bonne somme due
en tout cas décidé de d'hypothéquer ou
en tout cas de prendre marge du procès
cas ils ont des îles sont encore
réfugiés sont des immeubles qui valent
beaucoup
duhaime arriva troisième place lui il ya
deux flèches vertes c'est qu'il a
quadruples et qui tuent plaît même à
fait plus que ça
ce que l'ancien petit parti conservateur
avait québec solidaire en hausse et qui
ferme la marche mais en hausse par
rapport à l'an dernier le parti
québécois avec 365 mais qu'est ce que ça
nous dit michel ses tours de table à
dessus sur ce que ça dit quelque chose
qu'est ce que ça nous dit sur la suite
des choses
d'abord qu'il ya deux partis qu'ils sont
capables de faire campagne au maximum
des dépenses permises des autres en
plein sahel à faire ça ça c'est de la
visibilité qui ne sera pas là et donc il
faut un plan qui compense cette
visibilité là autrement il faut être
assez assuré ce moment l'homme à voir
les médias gratuits sorte pour avoir
cette visibilité là ça fait quel parti
libéral est en train d'hypothéquer son
vieux ganic pour la première fois que
des partis français le npd fait ça la
dernière campagne électorale
et il l'aura bourse extrêmement
rapidement alors le problème c'est pas
de
la capacité de rembourser après des
élections parce que on doit le faire
dans les 120 jours c'est pas très
longtemps c'est ça qu'il ya un mot non
plus on peut sembler mais il faut être
capable de remettre et la loi est très
sévère là dessus
et à première vue et à sa façon il ya
deux partis qui vont pouvoir aller au
maximum les dépassent les autres vont
avoir la plus cruciale jonatha
en même temps le parti libéral oui à une
capacité d'emprunt de capacité à
dépenser mais je pense que c'est le
parti qui n'en restituent à son la plus
problématique parce que pour les
services permettre d'aller au maximum de
ce qui pourrait dépasser est ensuite
remboursée pourquoi parce que c'est le
parti qui a le plus de difficulté à
lever des fonds il ya des chiffres
également à véhiculer cette semaine qui
démontre que non seulement le parti
basque et baic est le parti qui récolte
le moins d'argent sauf qu'il faut pas
oublier que en année électorale le
plafond de dons passe de 100 $ à 200 $
ce qui fait en sorte que tous les autres
partis ont réussi à augmenter
substantiellement le jury autour de 25
30% le nombre de leurs dons par rapport
à l'année précédente
or le parti brandit québec c'est à peu
près du pareil au même même en année
électorale il tire de la patte ont
beaucoup de difficultés et c'est le nerf
de la guerre d'être capable de mettre
des sous sur la table parce
qu'évidemment on pense à la publicité on
pense à tout ce qui est change pas
quatre mais j'ajoutais qu'en 2022 il
faut aussi passer au bénévolat le
bénévolat ça se paye c'est bizarre à
dire mais en 2022 si vous l'avons déjà
il y en a moins de besoins des
populations ça prend ça prend de
l'argent et si vous en avez pas bien ça
fait moins en moins de forces sur le
terrain pour opérer josé
wiberg et quand même certaines sources
qui frappe l'est d'abord il ya le parti
conservateur du québec qui bon quand
même en amasser un million à des
dizaines l'on pourrait dire quand même
parce que c'est ici s'il est où le
dernier des derniers arrivés là vraiment
sous éric duhaime la mobilisation est
quand même assez impressionnante et la
capacité de lever des fonds était
impressionnant monsieur du mcc même vrai
autobus ya pas un winnebago
mais c'est le fossé énorme abyssal je
dirais entre
les des finances de la carte du parti
libéral part opposé à québec solidaire
et le parti québécois parti québécois
qui a déjà été un parti au pouvoir en
rend fou quand même le répéter le bon
équilibre doit être sur son déclin mais
quand même il ya claire une dette de
plus de 2 millions etc oui
mais écoutez la trois cent mille quelque
chose ce sont des grenailles pour un
parti qui va se battre pour sa survie là
alors il ya vraiment un fossé et
ajoutons à ça aussi le fait que la pré
campagne dure depuis déjà quelques
semaines
c'est de ce sont des dépenses qui sont
non comptabilisés mais qui sortent aussi
des coffrets tu es parti donc pour les
partis qui sont moins nantis il va leur
rester coi pour la campagne il ya
vraiment un problème d'équité qui saute
aux yeux
vous avez dit le parti québécois a déjà
été au pouvoir et celui qui a porté le
parti québécois au pouvoir monsieur rené
lévesque à reus entend aujourd'hui le 24
où on a tellement parlé au printemps les
gens se disaient mais c'était une année
de
d'événements de lieux qui lui rendent
hommage de lieux pour faire connaître
monsieur lévesque aux plus jeunes aussi
avec des photos des bandes sonores y en
a une ou dans le quartier des spectacles
en gaspésie un événement dans taillon
actuellement moment où on se parle son
ancien comté à longueuil un mot là tu
sais c'est important où on a beaucoup
parlé avec l'intervention de monsieur
bush à la dernière fois mais revenons
sur monsieur lévesque lui-même tour de
table josé
c'est c'est bien parce qu'il ya des gens
qui l'ont pas connue qui auront qui vont
tendre l'oreille qui vont regarder
et s'il ya aussi ceux qui l'ont connue
qui s'en souvient plus
donc si oui je trouve que c'est
extrêmement importante devoir de mémoire
une dame assez cruel parce que ça tombe
dans la nuit ou le parti qu'il a fondé
et justement en très grande difficulté
mais rené lévesque et écouter on
pourrait en parler pendant deux heures
de temps pendant cinq heures de temps ça
a été un homme journaliste
extraordinaire ministres extraordinaire
premier ministre a promis un mandat du
mas spectaculaire deuxième mandat
catastrophiques d'accord mais écoutez
lorsqu'il est parti dans le déshonneur
un peu en 2085 était rejetée non
seulement par son parti pour les
québécois aussi lorsqu'il est décédé
deux ans plus tard ça a dû vous frappez
com - les fils et les filles deux
québécois qui avait dans le vieux
montréal devant l'ancien palais de
justice où sa dépouille était exposé
c'est comme si tout à coup on re
découvre et et c'est un peu comme si
beaucoup déjà regretter cet homme là et
regrettait de ne pas l'avoir soutenu un
peu plus et un peu mieux quand c'était
le temps mais écoutez dans la vie d'une
nation des hommes comme ça il en passe
pas ils en passent pas beaucoup oui
effectivement c'est rare jonathan
évidemment je n'ai pas la prétention de
pouvoir dire que je me souviens de
l'époque de rené les vagues j'ai pas la
même expérience vive allure collègues je
vais le dire et je veux dire comme ça
mais justement c'est l'occasion ici
belle c'est à dire de comprendre qui
était le personnage rené lévesque de
comprendre pourquoi les québécois lui
vous tant d'admiration dans l'infection
et moi j'adore entendre les gens qui
l'ont côtoyé qui peuvent parler de lui
chaude l'occasion est aussi de se
rappeler qu'il existe des oeuvres qui
sont qui sont tellement intéressant que
je pense un document est un document à
temps qui était produit par radio canada
qui est disponible sur audio le point de
mire sur rené lévesque est une série de
10 épisodes d'une heure que moi en
format cd j'ai brûlé j'ai dû coûter 5 fu
complet cette série lost je trouve c'est
l'occasion sera appliquée on doit on
doit assurer ce moment de pédagogie à
célébrer venir y comprendre qu'il était
aussi se dire que on aurait besoin de
plus de politiciens de 500 michel voilà
conclusion ça mau bientôt père 50 ans
que je trouve le politique au québec je
n'ai jamais couvert aussi que rené
lévesque même quand ça allait mal c'est
un policier est intéressant c'est
quelqu'un qui était novateur qui
cherchait des solutions pour s'en sortir
chauzy disait le deuxième a été
catastrophique oui c'est vrai mais en
même temps ils ont essayé toutes sortes
de nouvelles choses qui ont porté fruits
plus tard quand les habitations des
choses comme ça alors moi je ne crois
pas mal ça reste malgré tout ne plus
intéressera que l'homme qui est
intéressant que j'ai rencontrés
très bien dis merci beaucoup à vous
trois bonne soirée à très bientôt
bonsoir